so how about all that Call of Duty
advanced warfare multiplayer footage huh
look at these dudes it's jetting through
the air every which way it's crazy
getting up on rooftops flying through
windows turning invisible to sneak up on
fools spotting their glowing silhouettes
through walls climbing into like a big
mech suit huh does this remind any lots
of titanfall like a lot
yes you'd certainly be forgiven for
thinking that sledgehammers new entry in
the Call of Duty series bears strong
similarities to respawns high-flying
parkour fueled shooter there always was
a kinship there perhaps due to the fact
that the guys who launched us into the
modern warfare era went on to make
titanfall the speed of the action the
feel of the weapons the fragility of
your soldier the influence of call of
duty on titanfall has always been
apparent but titanfall distinguished
itself with its eponymous Titans and
with jump jet fueled while running
antics the latter created a whole new
spectrum of mobility which led to new
tactics new threats and a newly
invigorated multiplayer experience it
felt substantially different than call
of duty now along comes advanced warfare
with its own game-changing antics and
it's hard not to wonder just how much
overlap there is in advanced warfare
your exosuit enables seven different
abilities as far as we know and four of
them line up almost exactly with
titanfall advanced warfare has a cloak
ability titanfall has a cloak ability
advanced warfare has a see dude through
walls ability titanfall has a see dudes
through walls ability advanced warfare
has a boost health ability and a boost
speed ability titanfall has an ability
that does both advanced warfare has a
hulking mech suit with a big honkin gun
titanfall has well Titans okay that's
not really good parallel but when it
comes to the EXO abilities there is some
significant common ground even more
significant are the movement abilities
both games allow players to double jump
which results in a lot of roof hopping
and windowentry you can strike from a
wider variety of places in any given
environment so you must consider a
broader spectrum of offensive and
defensive strategies furthermore in
advanced warfare you can hover midair to
mess with where your opponent expects
you to be in titanfall you can wall hang
and accomplish the same thing a lot of
the tactical complexity that titanfall
introduced with its movement abilities
is present in Call of Duty advanced
warfare but there's one key difference
the boost dodge vs the wall run a boost
dodge in advanced warfare is a quick
dash you can execute at any time to
strafe quickly out of the way or change
direction sharply
in midair while running in titanfall is
a traversal tool dependent on a flat
vertical surface allowing you to
speedily cover distance and reach new
areas a boost dodge is a sharp staccato
beat wall running is a smooth legato
phrase the difference is crucial and it
sets the tone for to significantly
different play experiences the boost
dodge quickens the already fast call of
duty pace speeding up the tempo so that
seconds matter more than ever before
your target could be there one instant
gone the next your enemy could be across
the room now but in your face by the
time you aim down sights the boost dodge
ratchets up the intensity of evasion and
engagement but advanced warfare still
requires the same skills Call of Duty
has always demanded speed precision
awareness of your foe your weapons and
your environment titanfall on the other
hand demanded a new skill in order to
wall run successfully you couldn't just
know where the walls were you needed to
know their contours set your angles of
approach manage your momentum and know
where you're going next it can be a
smoother more prolonged maneuver so your
strategy has to include more potential
movements while running makes titanfall
combat feel more cohesive for a moment
to moment because you need to chain
together multiple actions to excel the
result being that though these two games
may have some striking similarities they
actually play very differently boost
dodging feels like exploiting the space
you're in wall running feels like
coexisting with your environment in Call
of Duty you feel like a visitor to the
places where you wage war in titanfall
you have to make them your home now if
it sounds like I'm favoring titanfall
here it's just because I have more
experience with it I had an absolute
blast playing advanced warfare
multiplayer matches and the kinetic
freedom of the double jump and the boost
dodge really feel like they have the
potential to reinvent Call of Duty
multiplayer in a more profound way than
we've seen in a long time personally I'm
excited but what about you does all this
mobility stuff sound cool or are you
worried about how it will change the
core gameplay join the discussion in the
comments below and be sure to check out
GameSpot's other video features on the
first reveal of advanced warfare
multiplayer action
you